hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys requested an arrow bonus video so
this is gonna be all about the new
heroes of the second half of arrow
season 3 power abhors a vacuum so let's
start with the big question what do you
do when your main hero vacates his role
one or more characters step into
Phillips so the second half of the
season is gonna be kind of a spin on the
Joseph Campbell archetype wheel for
everyone
everyone's characters the roles they
fill right now team arrow for instance
they're all gonna shift just a little
bit bad guys might seem like heroes or
be heroes outright and new bad people
are gonna step in to fill the void so
there will still be villains they'll be
heroes but the characters will shift
just a little bit I mean it's way more
complicated than that but what I'm
suggesting is is that Merlin and the
other team arrow members are going to be
the heroes while Oliver is away in
present-day that is the story's gonna
follow their journey we will still
follow Oliver's journey in the
flashbacks but this video is mostly
going to be about what's going on at
present-day
in case you're not familiar Joseph
Campbell wrote this book called hero
with a thousand faces it talks about the
different archetypes that characters can
embody in a story and some of the
similarities that all big epic stories
have just in case you're not caught up
on arrow careful for spoilers through
episode 9 I have to reference some
specific moments in the show so rewind
all the way back to season 1 just for
simplicity's sake just taking the show
at face value Oliver is the protagonist
the stories about his journey to
becoming the Justice League super hero
Green Arrow
Malcolm Merlyn is the main villain that
Oliver has to defeat he has to defeat
Darth Merlyn before he can call himself
a Jedi
oh wait nope nope wrong franchise isn't
it crazy though to think about arrow
through the star wars lens I guess in
that scenario Oliver would ultimately
have to redeem Merlyn so that is
something to file away in the maybe part
of your mind palace I think it's gonna
be like season 7 or 8 before Merlyn ever
finds any Redemption and they might not
even get there I think ultimately Merlyn
is on a Redemption arc but I think the
story would be way less interesting if
they let him achieve that he's always
gonna be better as a tragic character so
even if he's gonna be a hero in the
second half of arrow season 3 I don't
think he's gonna end the season that way
so pushing deeper into the Lazarus Pit
year when you look at the story from
different viewpoints of each of the
characters you know everyone's role or
their archetype changes depending on
which character you're thinking about so
malcolm merlyn for instance is always
going to be the hero of his own story
back during arrow season one like after
that was slowly coming to a close like
when they were finishing that season the
writers said that Malcolm Merlyn is
essentially an evil version of Batman of
Bruce Wayne if you remember in Batman
Begins whatever Christian Bale is asked
to assassinate that thief and he chooses
not to because Bruce Wayne he's a good
person they said that in arrows version
of events like in their timeline Malcolm
Merlyn probably did kill that person so
imagine if Bruce Wayne had gone evil
like if he gone dark that's who Malcolm
Merlyn is I totally buy John Barrowman
is an evil Bruce Wayne and that's
probably how they sold him on the role
when they first cast him so if someone
went up to John Barrowman said who is
the hero of arrow he probably said Oh
Malcolm Merlyn of course my character it
just he has some crazy methods he goes a
little overboard sometimes but
ultimately he has good intentions so
when I say that Merlyn is going to be a
hero of the second half of arrow season
3 it's gonna be partially through his
own viewpoint in the case of the other
characters like team arrow for instance
it'll be more literal don't be actual
heroes they'll have good intentions and
good methods although I do think that
Black Canary is gonna lose her or I
should say Laurel I mean she's gonna be
wearing the costume but she's not gonna
be totally full on Black Canary calling
her Black Canary is like calling Oliver
Green Arrow you know even where Oliver's
been he's had five years of training
plus the three years of the show so far
and he's still not Green Arrow so just
because Laurel puts the costume on
doesn't mean she's gonna be Black Canary
for all intents and purposes let's just
continue to call her Laurel just like a
more stabby version of Laurel if anyone
is confused to about who the other
characters are so I think that Thea is
essentially like the Mia Dearden
character and Roy is Arsenal he's not
gonna be a red arrow really I think in
terms of like all these new characters
becoming heroes in the second half I
think Thea is actually the biggest
x-factor she's like the biggest
trickster in all this because she's kind
of playing both sides
I mean Merlyn is trying to bring people
closer to him he's trying to like play
on their emotions like he wants to keep
Thea wants to keep his family close he
wants team arrow to start trusting him
more I think he really just wants their
protection I don't know if he actually
has their interests at heart
maybe Thea's I just I really like the
idea of Thea
a low-key character jumping back and
forth between the heroes in the villains
although technically Merlin really isn't
as much of a villain this season thus
I'm calling him kind of a hero certain
characters have certain archetypes
Joseph Campbell has seven specific
archetypes that he talks about there's
the hero the mentor the guardian of the
threshold the Herald the shapeshifter
the shadow and the trickster notice that
none of those things say villain so like
Merlin for instance is clearly the
trickster in most scenes but sometimes
thea is sometimes Felicity is the Herald
sometimes she's the guardian of the
threshold each of the characters is
gonna shift around so it's actually
gonna be really complicated but in a
very general sense most of these
secondary characters are going to assume
the hero role I'll be really interested
to see how this plays out in the like
the latter half of the second half of
the season really it's like the next
block of five episodes that I think is
going to be the next arc and then it'll
be a new story after that Stephen Amell
has talked about how like the arc of the
show changes within each season so like
the first half of the episodes like
during the fall that's one specific arc
then in the second half of the season
they actually have more episodes because
there's 23 per season so there's really
like two mini arcs so like the next mini
arc is gonna be the story of these
secondary characters becoming heroes and
yes I do think that we will get to the
Justice Society team-up by the end of
the season but first those characters
have to become heroes before they can
add the hero team-up so if we are gonna
get ajust a society art it's gonna be
the last couple of episodes the season
it's gonna be like the second mini arc
in the second half of this season
so what about Oliver though when is he
coming back and how is he coming back
that these are the really big questions
and in case you haven't ever read it
before here are the different steps and
Joseph Campbell's hero's journey so it
gives us an idea of what's next for
Oliver heroes are introduced to the
ordinary world where they receive the
call to adventure they're reluctant at
first or they refuse the call but are
encouraged by a mentor to cross the
first threshold and enter the special
world where they encounter tests allies
and enemies they approach the innermost
cave crossing the second threshold where
they endure the ordeal they take
possession of their reward and are
pursued on
back to the ordinary world they crossed
the third threshold experience a
resurrection and are transformed by the
experience then they returned with the
elixir a boon or a treasure to benefit
the ordinary world the elixir just
represents either knowledge or an item
or an artifact something of power Marc
Guggenheim and the other riders on arrow
don't you know strictly adapt the Joseph
Campbell mythology like their storyline
but there are a lot of similarities so
there are some parallels that we can
draw the biggest question I think we all
have is what is the mechanism of
Oliver's return and to when are we gonna
get our big Justice Society team-up a
lot of you been pointing to that fan art
at the Lazarus Pit that Stephen Amell
was sharing on his Facebook page you
know yes Marc Guggenheim has said he's
reversed his decision to not do
superpowers on arrow but I think the
Lazarus Pit on air or whatever they end
up doing will be something much more
practical like they'll still play it as
realistic as possible they just did
mirakuru in season 2 so magical elixir I
don't think is gonna be as big of a
thing you know no miracle cures but I do
think that it's gonna be something tied
to the league like some of their methods
and someone's going to be using that to
help Oliver to bring him back from the
edge of death very important remember
Malcolm Merlyn said back in season 2
Nanda Parbat was a place where death
does not have meaning the title of
episode 15 this season is Nanda Parbat
even if Oliver does not come back in
that episode I think we're gonna learn
how he's going to come back for those
that are wondering though episode 14 is
actually gonna be a really big episode
it's called the return and no it's not a
reference to Oliver returning and it's
not a reference to Slade returning
because Deathstroke is gonna be in the
episode too it's actually about Colin
Donnell coming back as Tommy Stephen
Amell posted this picture to Facebook
saying we would not shoot our 60th
episode of arrow without collar Donal so
the return is all about what he does in
the episode it's all based on that and
no I don't have any idea what he's going
to be doing in the episode I think it's
gonna be a flashback just like when
Tommy showed up at the beginning of the
season the next episode of arrow is
gonna air on January 21st that's
Wednesday here's the synopsis in the
aftermath of Oliver's fight with Raja
ghoul Diggle and Arsenal continue to
protect the city in arrows absence
however after three days without hearing
from Oliver they begin to fear the worst
happened to their friend Felicity
refuses to believe that Oliver would be
dead until Merlyn pays the team a
surprise visit Thea suspects there's
something more behind Oliver's
disappearance and asked Merlyn for a
favor
meanwhile ray tests a new part of his
suit and Laurel takes up the mantle of
the Black Canary I have done a video
that talks a little bit about what some
of those other episodes are going to be
about just like the general are so not
super spoiler or anything so I had a
link in the description if you guys want
to watch that I am working on another
flash bonus video but I'm probably gonna
do an agent Carter video NYX because
that show premieres tomorrow I will be
doing weekly videos so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
supposedly you know even like real
critics are going crazy about it so I'm
actually really excited my next flash
video is probably gonna be a character
video but feel free to leave me your
requests right now if you're on your
mobile phone or on your tablet though
there's new mobile links you can click
on up here it's the same as the links
that I over here but click here to learn
all about the flash rogues coming up in
the second half of the season and click
here to learn all about those other
episodes of arrow thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five happy
new years everyone I will see you
tomorrow in 2015
you